it's a new week and that means new
releases and this week we're going back
to Jacinto and fightin locust with Gears
of War Ultimate Edition originally
released in 2006 the new game is fully
remastered at 1080p with 60fps for
multiplayer you also get 90 minutes of
new campaign content that was originally
released on PC go back and relive the
glory days of using a torque bow to blow
a guy up or snag a boom gun to blow a
guy up or melee someone with a frag
grenade to blow a guy up all good
choices start chainsawing locust faces
on the 25th also this week Capcom is
releasing the first six Mega Man games
and adding fancy bonus features in the
Mega Man legacy collection
high-definition versions of Mega Man
through Mega Man 6 are offered along
with a challenge mode which will take
sequences and pieces from the games and
turn them into challenges maybe
something like fighting all the Mega Man
bosses in a row the mode will save and
upload replay data so the world can you
and awe your talents there's also an
enemy database so you can just practice
boss fights and mega fans will
appreciate the museum with sketches art
and other visual goodies the Legacy
Collection is out on the 25th NFL fans
and Odell Beckham jr. fans should take
note that NFL 16 releases this week on
last and current gen playstation and
xbox the game boasts total control
passing where you can place the ball
where only a receiver can get it with
body relative throws and you also get
receiver defender controls where you
dictate the outcome of each passing play
while the ball is in the air for the
first time ever in madden game modes
include connected franchise madden
ultimate team and skills trainer looking
good and you can start making plays on
the 25th also this week we get a blend
of turn-based movement with real-time
elements to concoct the action puzzler
game known as nova 111 pilot your trusty
orange vessel through mysterious and
foreign planets in this quirky sci-fi
adventure your mission is to fix space
time and search out the scientists lost
in the aftermath of the universe's
greatest science experiment you can
shift the odds in your favor by
collecting new abilities and upgrade
modules for your ship but the greatest
weapon you'll ever
this science start bending time on the
25th going to quickly burn through a few
titles dishonored definitive edition is
coming to current gen consoles this week
one piece pirate warriors 3 makes its
way to North America and Europe and
although ps4 owners got started August
nineteenth Xbox one and PC players get
their crack at black ops 3 beta August
26 shut chiemi is a cute I'm up about
the story of the fishy defending his
home waters against an army of
mysterious invaders squids pelicans
reverse Merman bears for some reason and
more are overrunning the Seas and it's
up to you to stop them with a goldfish
size memory rounds on the last 10
seconds with another 10 seconds to pick
your next power up but the catch is not
all of them are good this fast paced
guppy has two to four player local co-op
loads of wacky power-ups crazy songs
weird enemies and bosses lots of
unnecessary hats cross save and trophy
support it's even got online
leaderboards Jerome a dream of sushi but
gamers dream of shut Chi me and it's out
on the 25th finally are you ready to
play until dawn and see who lives and
who dies it's up to you whether you
realize it or not making decisions that
will have lasting effects way later on
in the game that's right throwing that
snowball could kill someone or maybe
snooping in a book bag could save
someone's life maybe everybody's dead
and you don't even know it who's to say
but the storytelling is pretty good and
I lost see all those gory deaths so
let's get into this until dawn makes its
exclusive ps4 debut on the twenty-fifth
for further details visit gamespot com
release dates are based on retailer
listings and are subject to change see
you next week